[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous heureux de
vous retrouver pour une nouvelle semaine
de sens public 90 minutes de débats et
de reportage pour donner du sens à
l'actualité voici le sommaire de ce 23
janvier la réforme des retraites
présentées en conseil des ministres
aujourd'hui c'est un volet important
pour les politiques et parlementaires
qui s'ouvrent mais le destin de cette
loi et de sa mesure phare là je l'égale
repoussé à 64 ans dépendra aussi et
surtout de la rue
c'est l'histoire d'un président de la
République qui lutte contre son propre
peuple qui ne veut pas de cette réforme
ce sera aussi l'histoire d'un président
de la République qui luttera contre sa
jeunesse mobilisée on va décortiquer les
stratégies des oppositions de l'exécutif
des syndicats avec cette question
centrale qui pourrait céder et puis
c'est un second thème d'actualité que je
vous propose ce soir nous partirons en
Iran plus de 4 mois après le début de la
mobilisation des femmes contre la
répression que devient le mouvement
peut-on déjà parler de révolution et
aussi pourquoi le régime iranien cible
la France depuis plusieurs semaines ne
ratez pas l'analyse de nos experts dans
45 minutes mais d'abord donc cette étape
importante dans le calendrier de la
réforme des retraites le Conseil des
ministres avec un gouvernement qui se
veut droit dans ses bottes quand un
calmé même après les importantes
mobilisations de la semaine dernière le
gouvernement maintient son cap la
réforme des retraites a été présentée en
conseil des ministres avec une mesure
sur laquelle l'exécutif n’entend pas
revenir le report de l'âge de départ à
64 ans la pierre angulaire de la réforme
une des éléments de la réforme qui
garantit le retour à l'équilibre donc
c'est tout à fait fondamental et c'est
un point sur lequel nous savons qu'il y
a un désaccord avec les organisations
syndicales mais revenir sur ce point
serait renoncer au retour à l'équilibre
et donc manquer de responsabilité pour
les générations futures pistes
d'aménagement de la réforme circulait
toute rejeté pour l'heure pas de
sanction pour contraindre à l'embauche
de seigneur ni de dispositifs
particuliers pour les personnes ayant
travaillé 44 ans et au passage les sont
confirmés que le débat au Parlement
devra se faire dans un temps contraint
pas plus de 20 jours à l'Assemblée
nationale dans le même temps les
oppositions montent au créneau en vue du
débat en hémicycle nous nous sommes le
premier groupe d'opposition notre rôle
c'est évidemment de mener la bataille à
l'Assemblée nationale et nous déposerons
d'ailleurs une notion référendaire parce
que nous souhaitons qu'il existe
des retraites elle soit tranchée par les
Français vient référendum bien sûr de
son côté la France insoumise entend bien
s'opposer au texte mais sans obstruction
normalement sur si on a du temps pour
discuter nous on a toujours dit qu'on
prendrait et on fera en sorte que le
débat est dur pour que les Français
puissent se mobiliser à l'heure actuelle
ça n'est pas la stratégie que nous
allons utiliser nous allons créer les
conditions d'un débat donc vous nous
dites il y aura pas 1000 amendements par
député de la France prochaine étape pour
le texte l'examen en commission à partir
du 30 janvier à la veille de la
prochaine mobilisation à terre syndicale
et je vous présente tout de suite les
invités de ce premier débat de sciences
publiques Christelle craquelais bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directrice de BVA
opinion Rémi bourguignon bonsoir
bienvenue directeur scientifique de la
chair transformation et régulation de la
relation au travail à l'Université Paris
Est Créteil Benjamin Morel bonsoir
Benjamin constitutionnisme mettre le
conférence en droit public Paris 2
Panthéon Assas et Mathieu croissanto
bonsoir Mathieu bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi évidemment Christelle gravelas on
vient de le voir c'est le temps
politique qui qui s'ouvre avec la
présentation de ce texte en conseil des
ministres mais quand même comment
l'opinion sort-elle de cette première
séquence de manifestation jeudi samedi
est-ce qu'elle est renforcée dans son
hostilité au texte alors on a toujours
enfin là dans les enquêtes qui ont été
publiées une majorité de Français qui
estime être contre cette réforme un
soutien qui est majoritaire à la au
mouvement et globalement quand même une
mesure voilà qui cristallise un peu les
oppositions qui est celle de l'âge du
recul de l'âge de départ à la retraite
qui donc la principale mesure que les
Français rejettent dans les dernières
enquêtes qu'on a pu voir oui c'est
vraiment la mesure phare qui attire qui
attire les regards Rémi Bourguignons il
faudra évidemment juger ce mouvement sur
sa capacité à durer et peut-être aussi
les syndicats sur leur capacité à
maintenir ce front unique qu'est-ce qui
pourrait les arder pour l'instant ça
tient c'est bon voilà on sait en
coulisse que il y a eu par exemple débat
sur la date de la deuxième grande
journée de mobilisation qu'est-ce qui
pourrait les arder ce front pour le
moment effectivement ce front syndical
tient et il a de bonnes raisons de tenir
un bon moment parce que déjà il y a une
mesure assez symbolique c'est assez
facile de voir s'il va y avoir recul ou
pas c'est cette question de de là j'ai
donc ça laisse assez peu de possibilités
de sortir par des compromis qui auraient
donné des des voies de sortie à
certaines organisations syndicales
plutôt favorable à négociation et de la
même manière on est dans une année un
peu particulière pour le syndicalisme
puisqu'on est dans une année électorale
on vote dans presque toutes les
entreprises cette année et donc c'est
vraiment pas l'année où il faudrait
faire une erreur de communication donc
avec une opinion qui est défavorable à
cette réforme les syndicats ont plutôt
intérêt à tenir cette position ce qui
pourrait éventuellement créer des
difficultés c'est si dans les les
mobilisations à venir et bien des
violences commencé à arriver ce qui
pourrait amener certains syndicats
peut-être à changer de regard sur les
modes d'action à privilégier et à ce
moment-là on pourrait voir le front
syndical peut-être se disloquer oui
alors je reviens vers vous Christelle
krabel parce qu'effectivement dans la
dans les arguments du gouvernement il y
a souvent l'argument quand c'est-à-dire
le blocage du pays non et comment
l'opinion se situe par rapport à ça ça
peut rejoindre la violence et pas du
tout la même chose mais ça peut
rejoindre la violence oui alors en
général effectivement les Français
n'apprécient pas vraiment quand il y a
de la violence ça peut les inquiéter
notamment s'il y a des jeunes qui
viennent à se mobiliser voilà en général
il y a quand même un rejet de ces
débordements en revanche quand même pour
l'instant on a vraiment une majorité qui
approuve le mouvement donc si ça reste
des événements qui sont ponctuels qui
sont en marge du conflit et que le voilà
le reste de la manifestation se passe
bien il y a pas de raison voilà que ça
retourne l'opinion parce que il y a
quelques débordements ponctuels
historiquement le combat parlementaire
il se nourrit des manifestations enfin
c'est c'est presque des vases
communicants c'est absolument des vases
communicantes si vous prenez la loi
Savary si vous voulez si vous prenez la
loi sur le CPE si vous prenez 1995 en
réalité c'est toujours un peu le même
mouvement vous avez d'un côté une
opposition qui fait de l'obstruction
pour bloquer le débat au Parlement c'est
pas bloqué pour bloquer bloquer pour
bloquer ça permet de montrer que vous
êtes très très opposé mais en soi ça a
une capacité d'action limitée c'est
bloqué le temps que les manifestations
montent dans la rue une fois que les
manifestations montent dans la rue une
fois que vous avez des blocages et que
ces blocages sont soutenus par l'opinion
et bien vous avez autre chose ce qui se
passe et c'est ça que vise en règle
générale une opposition c'est le
fait que la majorité se fissure prenait
la loi Savary vous avez plusieurs
éléments de la gauche qui disent en fait
là on est en train de tuer le septainat
donc essayons de reculer prenez 1995 à
l'époque s'est balladuriens contre
Chirac on est donc encore dans la dans
les dans la l'assemblée et bien 1993
prenez le CPE à l'époque vous avez une
opposition entre d'un côté les villes
Pinistes et de l'autre les sarkozymes
avec certains élus qui vont dire
attendez là on est en train de
s'affaiblir donc il faut renoncer il
faut rétropédaler l'objectif de
l'opposition c'est de faire monter la
mayonnaise dans la rue le temps que la
majorité doute est fissure ce qui rend
ensuite beaucoup plus difficile de mener
la réforme à bien Mathieu le président
l'a dit il est sur sur la table du
Conseil des ministres depuis ce matin
est-ce que le texte peut encore bouger
alors si on en croit la déclaration du
Président de la République hier qui a
invité le gouvernement et les
parlementaires à aménagé le texte pour
répondre oui il y a maintenant un temps
politique qui s'ouvre à l'Assemblée
insistait le président de la République
mais attention que les opposants
n'espèrent pas trop ni trop vite parce
que il risquerait de de chanter pourquoi
des chanter mais d'abord parce que les
concessions ont déjà été faites d'une
certaine façon et on pourrait
s'interroger au passage sur la stratégie
ou le choix tactique d'Elizabeth borne
qui en lâchant la mesure phare du report
de l'âge légal à 65 ans pour lui
préférer les 64 ans où en s'aidant sur
les 1200 euros brut minimum pour les
pensions pour tous les retraités futurs
mais aussi actuels la première mise
c'est privé deux gestes majeurs qu'elle
aurait pu faire pour désamorcer la
colère d'une certaine façon oui mais
voilà il lui fallait à l'époque
convaincre les républicains de voter ce
texte sur ceci avait fait de ces deux
points des lignes rouges résultats elle
a préféré céder à Éric Ciotti calaru ce
qui lui ce qui ne lui a qu'à moitié
puisqu'on voit qu'aujourd'hui certains
députés LR traînent des pieds alors par
ailleurs on explique dans la majorité
que de toute façon il était illusoire de
croire que sortir ces deux gestes
auraient pu calmer les opposants après
les manifestations à partir du moment où
on l'a rappelé ici les syndicats étaient
opposés à toutes mesures d'âge y compris
les plus réformistes d'entre eux comme
comme la CFDT alors sur quels aspect le
texte peut-il encore éventuellement
alors pas sur la rage on dit que c'était
pas un totem mais son état et
probablement un peu plus sur les mesures
d'accompagnement et encore à condition
que cela n'obéit pas l'objectif
d'équilibre en 2030 et que cela ne
conduise pas à augmenter les impôts ça
ce sont les deux lignes rouges posées
par Gabriel Attal le ministre du Budget
ce week-end alors ça n'empêche pas non
quand même le concours Lépine des
nouvelles idées dans la majorité
certains rêvent de trouver la martingale
qui rassemblerait tout le monde et c'est
peut-être pas une mauvaise idée
d'ailleurs qui serait d'abandonner la
notion d'âge légal pour lui préférer le
seul le déterminant qui serait la durée
de cotisation donc les cas fameuses 43
annuités ça va pas tout le même effet
sur les comptes publics si on supprime
évidemment là je légale mais en tout cas
ça serait possible ça serait ça serait
peut-être une mesure de justice d'autres
modèles par exemple ont imaginé qu'on
mettra contribution les entreprises ça
c'était pas la voix de François Bayrou
sans succès il propose aujourd'hui de
revenir sur les 35 heures attention en
portant le temps de travail hebdomadaire
à 35 heures et demie par semaine ce qui
permettrait selon leur calcul de dégager
quelques 2 milliards pour de ressources
supplémentaires pour financer des
mesures de d'accompagnement plus
généreuses là encore chou blanc
l'initiative a même plutôt agacé au
sommet de l'État donc pas de succès pour
ça reste quelques sujets quand tu as en
a parlé dans son sujet d'ouverture comme
l'emploi des seniors même si le
gouvernement s'est dit ouvert et en même
temps il n'a pas pris de mesure
coercitives dans la présentation de son
projet au conseil des ministres ce qui
montre peut-être que ça ça peut être
discuté à l'Assemblée quant au fait que
les personnes qui ont commencé à
travailler à 20 ans cotiseront 44 et non
43 ans ce qui est quand même une des
principales inégalités de ce projet de
loi assez incompréhensible pour tout le
monde pas seulement pour l'opposition là
rien n'est prévu en revanche mais il y a
fort à parier que ce point de crispation
ne pourra tenir dans la durée alors vous
parliez de l'emploi du Seigneur si je
vous propose d'écouter tout de suite le
ministre du Travail Olivier du soft à la
sortie du Conseil des ministres sur ce
thème c'est obligation de publicité et
donc de transparence sur les résultats
qui sont les siens en matière d'un texte
seniorer l'objet d'une fonction
financière comme c'est le cas pour
l'index égalité professionnelle entre
les femmes et les dessins ensuite nous
aurons un temps d'observation comme avec
chacun d'ex et l'objectif est non pas de
déterminer des notes ou de donner des
bons points des mauvais points mais
plutôt de regarder les évolutions et ce
qu'il est acté c'est que en cas de
dégradation la situation en tout cas de
non-ente des objectifs il y a une
obligation de négociation d'un accord
sur l'emploi des seigneurs dans
l'entreprise concernée
Rémi bourguignon le Medef on sait est
hostile un index Seigneur trop
contraignant est-ce que pour joignez ce
que disait Mathieu croissant dans
l'instant est-ce que là il y a du lest à
lâcher pour le gouvernement
sur près des syndicats en tout cas
si le gouvernement veut sortir avec un
compromis il y a pas beaucoup de pistes
en fait il y a cette question de l'âge
qui aujourd'hui cristallise absolument
toutes les attentions et tant qu'on ne
sortira pas de ça on ne voit pas comment
il pourrait renouer le dialogue en tout
cas sur cette réforme des retraites sur
avec les organisations syndicales donc
les solutions effectivement ont été
évoquées serait de parler plutôt de la
durée de cotisation ce qui permettrait
quand même de régler la question
budgétaire alors certes avec une
efficacité moins importante ça
permettrait de tenir les objectifs de la
de la réforme sans bloquer sur quelque
chose nous les syndicats on dit de toute
façon il ne reviendraient pas dessus et
on ne les voit pas donc tous les autres
aménagements sont sont importants
méritent discussion mais aujourd'hui ils
sont un peu inaudibles dans le débat en
tout cas dans le débat social et dans la
mobilisation parce que ça paraît des
mesures techniques mais on passe à côté
de quelque chose c'est que cette
question de l'âge est devenue symbolique
est-ce que si on rentre un peu dans la
finesse de des arguments ou des
revendications de des différents
syndicats il y a une mesure sur la je
sais pas la CFDT un peu plus en pointe
et qui permettrait d'obtenir un peu de
mensuer on a bien compris le discours de
lamberger il est ultra clair tant qu'à
la mesure d'âge on reste mobilisé mais
bon voilà on sait bien que c'est la
posture générale et puis ce qui peut se
discuter autour d'une table il y a la
mesure d'âge qui bloque mais la CFDT n'a
jamais dit qui a été contre le fait
qu'on puisse travailler plus longtemps
c'est pour ça que la question de la
durée de cotisation pourrait être un
sujet de discussion et là pour le coup
on verrait des désaccords entre
organisation syndicale assez net donc il
faut bien distinguer la durée de
cotisation et le fait de travailler plus
longtemps et puis cette question de
l'âge ouais sur quoi repose l'hostilité
une majorité de Français là aussi si on
rentre un peu plus dans dans le détail
sur quoi sur parle beaucoup de justice
ou d'injustice c'est quoi l'inquiétude
face à l'avenir c'est quoi les c'est un
peu tout ça il y a vraiment un sentiment
assez profond d'injustice avoir le par
les Français ont le sentiment à la qu'on
ne demande pas les mêmes efforts à tout
le monde et je revenais notamment sur
cette question de l'emploi des seniors
il y a vraiment l'impression que certes
on va reculer la durée de cotisation ou
l'âge légal de départ en retraite mais
finalement est-ce qu'on maintient les
seniors en activité est-ce qu'on leur
permet soit de se reconvertir soit
d'aller jusqu'au bout non pour la
plupart des Français et donc ils ont le
sentiment peut-être que les entreprises
les dirigeants sont pas suffisamment mis
à contribution ça nourrit un peu ce
sentiment d'injut plutôt profil bas
depuis le début depuis plusieurs
semaines parce que pour pas donner des
sentiments que c'est la la réforme
voulue par le MEDEF
dans l'opinion une volonté qui soit
davantage mis à contribution notamment
sur cette question là et puis le
deuxième sujet c'est une question un peu
de pédagogie c'est vrai que pendant
longtemps alors souvent les réformes des
retraites n'ont jamais été très
populaires mais il y avait quand même
dans l'opinion le sentiment d'une
nécessité au moins d'un point de vue
budgétaire là on est après le covid
après le quoi qu'il en coûte et cet
argument d'équilibre budgétaire passe
beaucoup moins dans l'opinion et du coup
bah c'est un élément en moins un élément
en tout cas qui contribue aussi à cette
opposition
et je revenais d'ailleurs sur ce que
vous disiez en tout cas là où le
gouvernement tient c'est qu'il a quand
même l'appui de sa base dans nos
enquêtes on voit quand même que les
retraités sont majoritairement pour
cette réforme les sympathisants LRM le
son de façon massive les sympathisants
LR même si c'est un peu moins ils sont
aussi majoritairement pour cette réforme
donc il y a toute la posture de
réformateur que joue Emmanuel Macron et
qui est important et pour l'instant sa
base le suit Benjamin Morel il y a une
question de légitimité aussi je trouve
dans ce conflit parce que Emmanuel
Macron il s'appuie sur sa légitimité de
président en disant j'ai fait campagne
avec un âge légal même à 65 ans si on
s'en souvient et puis après il y a la
question de la légitimité du rapport des
Français avec leur syndicats avec leurs
partis politiques un éloignement ou ce
sentiment peut-être que ils peuvent pas
vraiment peser sur l'avenir d'une
réforme et si vous êtes d'accord pour
dire que ce mot légitimité est important
dans les dans les jours et dans les
semaines qui viennent évidemment c'est
un mot extrêmement important parce que
vous avez un Emmanuel Macron qui dit
voilà j'ai été élu pour faire cette
réforme d'un point de vue juridique
c'est très discutable tout bêtement
parce que le Président de la République
n'a aucune compétence pour déposer un
projet de loi ou pour le faire adopter
c'est quelque chose dans lequel le
président de la République n'a qu'un
pouvoir cette promulgale texte qui a été
voté par le Parlement donc dire j'ai
reçu un blanc simple c'est discutable
d'un point de vue juridique et d'un
point de vue politique parce que
évidemment au premier tour vous
choisissez au second tour vous éliminez
ensuite sur les législatives on a une
majorité relative et on a une majorité
relative avec beaucoup de députés qui
ont été élus en 2017 dans des
circonscriptions de centre gauche qui
étaient à l'époque des fiefs de la
majorité qui sont devenus pour beaucoup
des sièges éjectables et qui se posent
la question de l'après comment arriver à
être réélu dans cinq ans dans quatre ans
et demi sachant que une partie de mon
électorat vient plutôt du centre gauche
et ça rejoint l'argument que vous nous
donniez tout à l'heure sur la fragilité
la fragile de la de la majorité
d'ailleurs pour les modem et donc là il
y a un sujet qui va être un sujet de
légitimité des parlementaires par
rapport à leur base et du président par
rapport à son élection de l'autre côté
les syndicats faut pas oublier épisode
des gilets jaunes il faut pas oublier
non plus l'épisode 2019-2020 après des
syndicats que l'on disait mort lors de
la crise des gilets jaunes on voit que
2019-2020 et bien montre que il y a une
capacité de mobilisation il y a une
capacité des syndicats d'incarner du
point de vue de l'opinion une
contestation sociale à oui mais on a
pardon nous interrompre on a aussi vu le
mouvement SNCF juste avant les vacances
de Noël avec un mouvement qui qui
dure hors syndicat hors syndicat et
sursis et souvent des syndicats y
compris d'ailleurs je parle sous votre
contrôle en 2019-2020 qui était dépassé
par leur base donc les directions
syndicales si elles ne veulent pas être
totalement légitimées pour reprendre ce
mot compliqué et bien ont besoin malgré
tout de montrer qu'elle colle à
l'opinion qu'elle colle à leur base
qu'elle colle à l'opinion qui demain
peut les soutenir qu'elle colle
également à la jeunesse qui aujourd'hui
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure la question
des personnes âgées il y a le regard
inverse justement sur cette jeunesse qui
s'inquiète de cette réforme ce qui fait
que la possibilité pourrait Emmanuel
Macron de bouger et compliqué parce que
ce serait dit à gros et bien vous ne
m'avez pas réellement élu pour cette
réforme quid de mon quinquennat la
possibilité pour les syndicats de
rétropédalés et tout aussi compliqué le
conflit Matthieu ce que dit benjamin est
très juste sur la légitimité au sens
juridique au sens politique il faut
quand même souligner qu'il y a une forme
de cohérence parce que ça faisait quand
même partie de son programme
présidentiel ça lui a suffisamment coûté
on l'a dit à l'époque en termes de voix
de soutien et ça m'a quand même pas
empêché d'arriver en tête au premier
tour d'être élu au second dans les
conditions que vous avez décrites c'est
sûr que là c'est pas un blanc ça on vote
pas par adhésion au programme d'Emmanuel
Macron au second tour en 2022 on vote
pas pour cette réforme là mais ça a
quand même aussi permis et malgré tout
ça à son parti d'arriver en tête à
l'Assemblée même s'il n'a pas la
majorité absolue mais les gens ont voté
en connaissance de cause c'est pas
quelque chose qui était planqué c'est
pas quelque chose qui est sorti du
chapeau trois mois après l'élection
comme ça avait été le cas pour Jacques
Chirac et un Juppé en 1995 ou même pour
Nicolas Sarkozy François Fillon et Eric
woert en 2010 Rémi bourguignon
la question de la stratégie d'Elisabeth
borde math m'a tué en parler aussi dans
sa chronique à l'instant effectivement
est-ce qu'elle a alors moi j'ai commencé
avec doigt dans ses bottes ça s'est
références 95 il y a une phrase qu'on
entend tout le temps c'est le grain
moudre qui était cher à André Bergeron
l'ancien secrétaire général de Force pas
sur les retraites
à la télévision il dit qu'il reste droit
et pour la faire de l'appartement
je sortirai de ce débat un peu plus
érudit mais oui moi j'étais persuadé que
c'était livré bon ben voilà et donc le
grain moudre de André Bergeon c'est
aussi une expression qu'on va employer
qu'on va continuer d'employer dans les
dans les prochains jours est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ce que dit Mathieu
c'est à dire la chute du du grain à
moudre un peu trop vite Elizabeth borne
je sais pas si c'est trop vite s'il y
avait pas de volonté de trouver un
compromis et de négocier la réforme avec
des organisations syndicales après tout
c'était pas la peine de s'engager sous
le coup en revanche il fallait majorité
parlementaires et donc c'était ça qu'il
fallait négocier très tôt donc ce que ça
traduit ça traduit le fait que la toute
sa stratégie tout ça tactique a été
orientée vers la recherche d'une
majorité parlementaire et certainement
pas d'un accord avec les organisations
syndicales je pense que il y a une
conscience assez nette au niveau du
gouvernement sur le fait que il n'y a
pas de terrain d'entente possible et
donc il ne cherche pas l'obtenir les
dernières déclarations montrent à
nouveau une fermeté et une détermination
du gouvernement et n'ouvre pas du tout
la voie la discussion chrysal Crapelet
je parlais de l'éloignement des Français
vis-à-vis de leur syndicat est-ce que
c'est quand même une démonstration de
force à laquelle on a assisté jeudi à un
million à seulement une personne dans
dans les rues 250 points de
rassemblement dans tout le plat France
c'est sans doute trop tôt pour répondre
mais est-ce que ça ça redonne un peu de
confiance à une partie de l'opinion
française dans la capacité des syndicats
à peser sur l'avenir d'une réforme d'une
certaine façon oui sans doute que ça il
contribue ça contribue aussi
probablement à donner le sentiment que
les manifestations sont encadrées qu'on
revient dans un processus un peu
classique d'OPP par les syndicats après
c'est vrai que même si c'est un succès
même s'il y a des gens dans la rue nous
dans les enquêtes on voit bien que la
défiance qui touche les politiques elle
touche quand même plein d'institutions y
compris les organisations syndicales y
compris les parties d'opposition et
c'est pas parce que le mouvement est un
succès que il y a un front syndical et
ça c'est très important qui s'affiche
unie que derrière ils vont avoir une
très large majorité de personnes qui les
soutiennent ou qui ont une bonne image
des syndicats le président de la
République on l'a évoqué rapidement il
compte sur les parlementaires pour faire
évoluer le texte il l'a dit hier lors de
sa conférence commune avec le chancelier
allemand et eu ce temps social il y a
maintenant un temps politique qui
s'ouvre à l'Assemblée il faut le
respecter et donc moi je souhaite que le
gouvernement avec
les parlementaires à l'Assemblée
nationale puis au Sénat puisse
travailler le texte et l'aménager mais
je crois que là maintenant il faut
pouvoir avancer et s'engager et que le
gouvernement puisse faire son travail
avec le Parlement
avec sérénité la volonté de convaincre
et de faire avancer le pays alors là on
va rentrer dans notre débat sur une
question qui a une question de de
temporalité de maîtrise du calendrier et
on va rentrer un petit peu plus dans les
détails je me tourne vers Benjamin
j'allais dire les détails le dédale
peut-être aussi de de la Constitution et
j'appelle Steve Jourdain à nous
rejoindre pour avancer Olivier du somme
bonsoir Steve enfin j'ai la craque
confirmer aujourd'hui le gouvernement a
décidé de passer par un
plfssr je vais vous laisser expliquer
après pour faire adopter la réforme des
retraites et ce qui lui donnera la
possibilité de faire usage de l'article
47 1 oui allez-y c'est parti
47 ans c'est la nouvelle star à tout
moment on parle on va faire les
présentations on parle d'une procédure
procédure inédite sous la 5ème
République pour un projet d'une telle
ampleur vous l'avez dit Thomas pour
faire passer cette réforme des retraites
de l'exécutif va utiliser un
plssr un projet loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale rectificative c'est
déjà en soi un véhicule législatif rare
et la possibilité de recourir à
l'article 47- qu'est-ce que je disais
oui 47-1 on est bien
de la Constitution ce qui est important
dans cet article c'est l'article alinéa
de on va le voir si l'Assemblée
nationale ne s'est pas prononcer en
première lecture dans un délai de 20
jours après le dépôt d'un projet le
gouvernement saisi alors le Cénac qui
doit statuer dans un délai de 15 jours
si le Parlement ne s'est pas prononcé
dans un délai de 50 jours les
dispositions du projet peuvent être
mises en œuvre par ordonnance ou en gros
en très gros en immense le 47 1 autorise
le gouvernement à faire voter un texte
au triple galop ce qui permet de limiter
le temps de tes bas dans l’émission et
aucun gouvernement n'avait jusque là
utilisé cette procédure pour une réforme
des retraites non jamais les précédentes
réforme sont passées par une procédure
dite classique au Parlement Elisabelle
Bank aurait pu en faire de même mais
elle souhaite en tout cas en réalité
tous les blocages des oppositions éviter
de recourir la fameuse article 49-3 jugé
trop un peu populaire trop sensible
politiquement il faut dire qu'elle a
déjà utilisé 10 fois depuis son arrivée
à Matignon la première ministre pense
donc pouvoir en faire l'économie en
recourant à l'article 47 1 reste à
savoir si tout cela est vraiment moins
brutal et surtout bien constitutionnel
écoutez
il y a quelque chose qui a qui danse
déjà un outil anti démocratique c'est
l'article 47.1 comme parlementaire je
dis il n'y a aucune raison d'utiliser
des articles qui ne sont pas faits pour
ça et je dis monsieur Macron en
utilisant cet article vous portez la
marque d'une brutalisation et je crois
que le Conseil constitutionnel vous le
rappellera et il est possible que tous
débat soit jugés anticonstitutionnel le
Conseil constitutionnel pourrait-il
vraiment retoquer cette cette mesure ce
qui est certain c'est que Laurent Fabius
a attiré la semaine dernière l'attention
du Gouvernement sur ce point dans le
cadrage enchaîné on apprend que le
président du Conseil est constitutionnel
s'interroge sur l'usage de l'article 47
ans pour faire passer une réforme du tel
ampleur oui si on résume en clair un
réforme du système des retraites
pourrait être modifié réformés en une
cinquantaine de jours sans qu'un texte
ne soit voté en première lecture dans
aucune des deux Chambres du Parlement ça
serait tout simplement du jamais vu
Thomas merci beaucoup Steve alors je
vais je vais vous dévoiler un secret de
fabrication Steve va quand même appeler
Benjamin cet après-midi pour pour que
vous puissiez pas dire juste après bah
non vous vous êtes trompé donc c'était
parfait merci encore Steva c'était
nickel mais effectivement on a besoin de
vos de votre expertise parce que il y a
une question de calendrier c'est pour ça
que c'est intéressant parce que c'est
complexe à excusez-nous mais il y a une
question de maîtrise du calendrier par
le par le gouvernement on disait tout à
l'heure ça se joue dans la rue et au
Parlement donc plus on va vite au
Parlement plus on peut éventuellement
gagner la bataille c'est exactement
l'objectif de dispositif alors il y en a
d'autres il y a eu le temps législatif
programmée avec etc mais le gouvernement
a eu peur que ça fasse monter la
mayonnaise dans la rue un peu plus de
temps parce que fallait six semaines
donc on tombe sur ce dispositif il a pas
été créé pour ça pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
un 47-1 bah on a un 47-1 parce que à
l'origine c'est la même chose également
pour les projets de loi budgétaire il
faut voter votre pffss avant le 1er
janvier si vous n'avez pas de PLFSS au
1er janvier et ben les pensions vous
pouvez pas les verser donc ce faisant il
faut qu'il y a un texte qui soit voté
donc on a une forme de rétroplanning sur
les budgets et sur les budgets de la
Sécu le problème évidemment c'est que là
il y a pas d'impératif le 1er janvier
vous le comprenez bien alors on
l'applique au PLFSS rectificatif parce
que pour les PLFSS rectificatif on juge
qui peut y avoir une urgence si vous
avez une crise covid quelque chose qui
vous tombe dessus il faut vite modifier
vos comptes sociaux mais là il y a pas
d'urgence si la loi est votée en avril
en mai en juin ça va pas changer la face
des retraites et des comptes sociaux
donc là il y a une interrogation parce
que si le Conseil constitutionnel dit
aucun problème ça signifie que demain
toutes les réformes sociales pourrait
passer par ce type de véhicule or il
faut bien comprendre que ces 20 jours à
l'Assemblée si vous avez un peu
d'obstruction et que vous n'en êtes qu'à
l'article 2 au bout de 20 jours le texte
n'est pas voté il part directement au
Sénat et il se peut que ni l'assemblée
ni le Sénat n'est vraiment examiner le
texte avant la commission mixte
paritaire que dit Laurent Fabius dans
cette interview en fait il envoie un
gros drapeau rouge au gouvernement et
leur dit il faut un vote ce qui signifie
si vous en êtes à l'article 2 au bout de
20 jours vous avez deux choix soit vous
ne faites pas de vote et à ce moment là
et ben il y a un risque d'inconsnalité
soit vous forcez un vote mais il y a
qu'une façon pour forcer un vote c'est
d'utiliser le 49,3 et on y revient au
49-3 avec ce que disait Alexis Corbière
tout à l'heure dans un extrait de
d'interview de sur notre antenne a
priori pas de pas de d'excès la question
c'était est-ce que vous allez déposer
1000 amendements par par député de la
nuque ça reste ou pas c'est pas parce
qu'il le dit que ils le font pas un
moment du débat on nous dit un outil
classique quoi c'est un outil mais ils
vont le faire probablement de manière
très intelligente c'est-à-dire que la fi
est la nuque ont tout intérêt à ce que
il y a 49 alinéa 3 mais non pas intérêt
à avoir un gouvernement qui dise
regarder une en somme qu'à l'article 2
et nous n'avons plus débattre de rien
donc on va avoir une petite porte qui
porte le poids de l'obstruction
exactement et donc on va avoir une
obstruction beaucoup moins importante
mais qui sera suffisante pour atteindre
le mur des 20 jours pour qu'à la fin il
y a 49 Alina 3 parce que le gouvernement
n'a plus guère le choix après cette ces
offres de Laurent Fabius et qui
permettront la nuque de dire regarder
nous avons été constructifs et qui plus
est qui peut permettre de parasiter un
petit peu le texte du Gouvernement
est-ce qu'il faut bien lire tous ces
offres de Laurent Fabius ils disent
également qui va tirer à boulets rouges
sur les cavaliers sociaux on parlait
tout à l'heure de de l'index senior ça
c'est pointé comme étant un cavalier
social c'est quoi un cavalier social
c'est quelque chose qui n'a rien à voir
dans le texte c'est à dire ça n'a pas
d'incidence financière et donc ce qui
relève de la pénibilité ce qui relève du
de la citation à garder les seniors etc
tout ça pourrait être descendu par le
Conseil constitutionnel et si vous
laissez le temps au débat de s'inscrire
si vous avez des majorités à d'autres le
rnlr etc sur des amendements qui sont
constitutionnellement fragiles ou qui
embêtent sur le fond le gouvernement et
que ses amendements sont votés ça
signifie que vous avez un texte qui va
être en grande partie pas celui que le
gouvernement aurait rêvé qui peut tomber
un peu plus sous les canons du Conseil
constitutionnel et qu'à la fin et même
gouvernement peut se retrouver avec un
texte certes voté certes il finit
promulguée parce que pas totalement
censuré mais pas vraiment le texte qu'il
aurait souhaité d'un mot les
constitutionnalistes sont pas tous
d'accord sur sur l'analyse autour de
cette de cet article alors aujourd'hui
depuis l'interview de Laurent Fabius
avant il y a eu plusieurs positions chez
les conseillers dans un premier temps on
a dit c'est malin c'est cynique mais
c'est malin dans un deuxième temps on a
dit mais en fait quels sont les limites
potentielles aujourd'hui quand même
Laurent Fabius fait ce qu'il fait assez
rarement c'est à dire qu'il envoie des
signaux qui sont des signaux assez
clairs assez lourds qui fait qu'on ne
sait pas tout ce que fera le Conseil
constitutionnel mais on commence à avoir
une bonne idée si on revient à la
rue Rémi bourguignon et à l'action des
syndicats à la stratégie des syndicats
parce que notre débat on essaye de voilà
de décortiquer un peu la stratégie des
des et des autres
le carburant d'un tel mouvement
historiquement c'est quoi
on l'a dit les organisations syndicales
sont elles-mêmes assez fragiles malgré
tout et elle s'était quand même pas très
sûr d'elle avant la mobilisation de la
semaine dernière et beaucoup communiqué
avec des craintes sur la mobilisation et
ne sont pas encore assurés que il y a
d'autres journées de mobilisation donc
elles sont puissantes que la précédente
elles sont quand même assez assez
prudentes dessus là ce qui pousse les
organisations syndicales à jouer la
carte de ce mouvement et à jouer
jusqu'au bout c'est que quand même à
travers cette réforme une de plus se
joue la question de la place des
organisations syndicales dans
l'organisation de la protection sociale
qui historiquement quand même est un
sujet qui relève du paritarisme qui
relève des organisations patronales et
syndicales et vous disiez tout à l'heure
le patronat fait quand même un peu
profil bas et on l'entend pas beaucoup
d'une part pour le fond du sujet parce
qu'ils veulent pas
faire un soutien qui serait malvenu au
gouvernement mais probablement qu'ils
sont un peu embarrassés face à cet état
d'utilisation de la protection le calque
qui est en train de se jouer à travers
ça et c'est le pas sûr que le patronat
soit tout à fait d'accord avec le fait
qu'on dépossède aussi les organisations
patronales et syndicales de toutes voix
en matière de protection sociale
là si on probablement assez d'accord sur
le sur la sur la réforme et sur le fait
de travailler plus longtemps mais c'est
quand même le risque qu'à l'avenir les
différentes réformes à la fois en
matière de sécurité sociale de retraite
etc échappe aux organisations patronales
également et ça c'est pas forcément une
bonne nouvelle pour elle un petit bémol
c'est qu'ils étaient parfois très
contents que le gouvernement fasse le
boulot je pense que le chômage
quand le gouvernement on fait exactement
comme les patrons veulent placez plus
que votre poreux parce que ils savent
que de toute façon ils auront jamais
d'accord avec les syndicats et ça
marquait aussi les limites de notre
système paritaire enfin du paritarisme
c'est quand il y a des situations de
blocage pas trop dans les syndicats se
retourne vers qui vers l'état il y a une
tranchée on l'a vu sur lunédique à
l'époque on l'a vu donc sur la science
chômage on a vu sur agir Carco enfin les
régimes complémentaires donc avec la
question de la feuille de route comme
donne Audi partenaires sociaux qui est
parfois tellement cadré que ils ne
peuvent de toute façon pas tomber
d'accord mais il y a une question qui
est importante dans la temporalité c'est
que ce qui va fracturer le mouvement
syndical c'est le vote de la loi parce
que on a dans nos syndicats dans les
confédérations syndicales des syndicats
réformistes qui sont dit l'égalistes
c'est-à-dire qu'une fois que la loi est
votée c'est très rare de les voir dans
la rue pour continuer le mouvement pour
demander leur retrait de la loi c'est
arrivé
la CFDT a manifesté un peu je crois au
moment du CPE mais c'était pas un
mouvement qui avait été lancé par les
syndicats mais une sinon une fois que la
loi est adoptée une fois qu'elle est
votée généralement la CFDT la CFTC
l'INSA se retire du jeu parce que la loi
c'est la loi a pu ensuite on voit
comment on peut la changer alors que la
CGT ou est faux peuvent généralement au
sud peuvent continuer le mouvement on
l'a vu au moment de la Réforme verte
puisqu'on parle des syndicats vous avez
le contexte on va dire électoral
il y a si on le zoom encore un peu plus
si elle contexte de la CGT
qui partirait Martinez c'est son dernier
c'est son dernier mandat on le sait donc
Congrès a Clermont-Ferrand fin mars j'ai
déjà posé la question à un autre
interlocuteur sur ce plateau est-ce
qu'il y a un une possibilité un risque
je sais pas quel terme employé
dessusenchère entre les différentes
fédérations de la CGT oui assez
classiquement quand on approche
deschéances comme ça électorale interne
il peut y avoir ses effets de surenchère
les courants les plus réformistes ne
voulant pas laisser tout le terrain de
la revendication au plus au plus
contestataire mais là sur ce mouvement
ça joue probablement assez peu parce
qu'il y a un vrai alignement de toute
l'organisation contre contre cette
réforme et on a d'ailleurs pas vu de
tellement de surenchères c'est ce qui
est demandé c'est un retrait et là ils
sont tous absolument alignés derrière
dans les modes d'action éventuellement
après on pourra le voir dans les modes
d'action notamment quand on va venir sur
les blocages éventuellement etc là on va
on va peut-être avoir mais d'ailleurs on
aura des des tensions alors au sein de
la CGT pas forcément beaucoup sera
plutôt syndicale qu'on les retrouve
d'autant que le calendrier électoral
c'est un peu compliqué mais pour les
fédérations n'est pas forcément le même
que pour la Confédération on est par
exemple la Fédération mines énergie elle
a renouvelé son instance en juin dernier
donc elle n'est plus en campagne
électorale et puis il y a une dimension
qui est intéressante et je voudrais bien
vous entendre là-dessus Christelle
craplay c'est le rapport des Français au
travail et que historiquement
les les l'opinion est majoritairement
hostile à une réforme de retraite c'est
pas nouveau ça c'est c'est à chaque
gouvernement doit s'attaquer à un fond
du refus c'est toujours le point de
départ mais là il en plus ce rapport au
travail qui a totalement changé depuis
la crise covid oui il y a eu vraiment
une évolution dans le dans le rapport au
travail on le voit dans les enquêtes
qu'on peut faire sur les salariés
notamment dans les plus jeunes
générations et sans doute que ça change
aussi la perception de la retraite et
que cette idée en fait de repousser sans
cesse le moment où on va avoir peut-être
un petit peu de temps libre de moments
d'en profiter est encore plus rejeté et
puis l'autre fait c'est le travail mais
dans quelles conditions et si on nous
demande sans arrêt de travail plus
longtemps mais dans de mauvaises
conditions avec une forte pénibilité bah
du coup il y a aussi un rejet plus fort
de ce point de vue là et c'est ce qui
contribue aussi probablement au rejet de
cette réforme là en particulier même si
voilà il y a toujours eu un rejet des
réformes des retraites mais encore plus
fort cette fois-ci il y a un élément qui
a été relevé par David douka chef du
service politique au Parisien
Aujourd'hui en France et il y a quelques
jours il évoque le seul point commun
d'Emmanuel Macron Laurent Berger et
Philippe Martinez ça rejoint ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure ils sont tous les
trois Antoine effectuer leur dernier
mandat Benjamin Morel je veux bien vous
entendre là-dessus aucun des trois va
vouloir laisser le souvenir de quelqu'un
qui a cédé quoi vous voyez ce que je
veux dire oui bien sûr alors il y a des
intérêts syndicaux qui qui ont été
évoqués tout à l'heure et pour Emmanuel
Macron il y a un intérêt sur ce dernier
mandat parce qu'en réalité tout à
l'heure je disais cette réforme a priori
ne passerait pas si jamais la majorité
seracturé grosso modo si vous avez si
vous commencez à avoir une partie de la
majorité qui dit écoutez là on peut pas
aller plus en avant si vous avez LR qui
décide de ne plus jouer les appoints etc
et il y a plus de majorité c'est-à-dire
que tout le reste du quinquennat va être
un chemin de 3 pour Emmanuel Macron donc
arrivé à faire passer cette réforme pour
le président de la République c'est une
question pas de survie politique mais en
tout cas de survie du quinquennat dans
la gestion de la majorité pour la suite
et ça en effet aujourd'hui au vu des
lignes de fracture qu'on a vu se creuser
au sein de la majorité ne serait-ce que
ces derniers mois au vu des intérêts
stratégiques très divergents entre
François Bayroux Édouard Philippe etc
c'est un enjeu qui est un enjeu criant
sur la stratégie LR peut-être un mot
Mathieu parce que ils ont des vous nous
l'avez dit ils ont déjà quasiment obtenu
gain de cause les lignes rouges qu'ils
avaient posées bon elles ont pas été
franchis par le par le gouvernement mais
il y a quelques quoi divergences
partager parce que ils jouent leur image
de partie de gouvernement et c'est
essentiel pour les LR parce que vous
prenez l'assemblée par exemple il y a
pas un ancien ministre dans le groupe LR
c'est assez rare pour être noté
quasiment le cas aussi chez les
socialistes mais les deux grands partis
qui ont structuré notre vie politique et
qui ont gouverné la France depuis 50 ans
il ne compte plus de ministres dans leur
rang à l'Assemblée donc il y a cette
peur d'une surenchère de gens qui n'ont
jamais exercé de responsabilité au
niveau national et qui pourrait se
laisser aller à proposer tout et
n'importe quoi dans une logique
d'opposition et ça Éric soutif et
attention parce qu'il ne veut pas que
son parti devienne partie de surenchères
après il y a un risque majeur qui est de
relever par certains députés c'est le
risque de la dilution de devenir des
supplétifs et au fond de perdre leur
identité est donc leur utilité à quoi
sert LR si de toute façon quand on va
pour eux il vote les mesures que propose
l'exécutif et on voit bien cette espèce
de jeu de drague plus ou moins subtil
entre
l'exécutif sur le projet de loi
immigration sur les retraites qui durcit
à chaque fois ces positions croyant
faire plaisir ou LR et les LR à pâté un
peu coincé parce qu'ils ont profé et
promis les mêmes choses se souvenir que
les LR promettent même la retraite à 65
ans pendant la campagne de lyrics c'est
y compris pendant les législatives alors
aujourd'hui il joue les Robins des bois
mais ils étaient sur les positions
encore plus dures donc c'est c'est on
voit bien que l'exécutif essaie de les
coincer vous achetez leur vote et que LR
essaie d'exister et de ne pas
hypothiquer leur avenir alors on l'a dit
le bras de fer il joue en parallèle dans
la rue et au Parlement pour Manuel
Bompard député LFI c'est d'abord la
mobilisation populaire qui pèsera
nous déposera le haut autant
d'amendements que nécessaire pour
crédibiliser nos contre-propositions
défendre l'idée de la retraite à 60 ans
avec quarantaine unités pointé aussi les
incohérences et les mensonges du
gouvernement dans sa communication et
aider la bataille dans la société dans
la rue dans la mobilisation dans la
grève lui donner de la force et lui
donner l'encouragement mais pour
répondre à votre question très
précisément c'est pas par l'Assemblée
nationale on gagnera sur ce sujet ça me
paraît une évidence il faut que tous les
gens qui nous écoutent le comprennent si
on veut gagner sur ce sujet faut se
mobiliser
ce combat les syndicats d'abord avant la
nuque ou c'est mélangé c'est compliqué
parce que effectivement la mobilisation
c'est une démonstration de force et sa
témoigne d'un certain succès mais ça ne
dit rien de ce que pense quand même les
Français dans leur ensemble tout le
monde ne va pas manifester c'est quand
même plutôt une tradition à gauche et
nous on voit bien qu'il y a quand même
une partie des gens même si à
l'iminoritaire qui soutiennent le
gouvernement et puis que l'opposition a
du mal à capitaliser quand même sur
cette période là parce que même si c'est
un succès d'un point de vue mobilisation
nous dans les enquêtes on voit qu'ils
apparaissent pas forcément comme étant
plus crédible comme feu on n'a pas
l'impression qu'il ferait mieux s'ils
étaient au pouvoir et ça c'est un vrai
sujet parce que derrière il apparaissent
pas forcément comme une alternative et
sont pas forcément gagnants je dis bien
en terme d'opinion sur sur cette
séquence les soutiens c'est assez
basiquement le ceux qui ont voté
majorité présidentielle Renaissance
aujourd'hui et les LR oui en termes
politiques il y a vraiment un clivage
très très net les sympathisants lrem ou
ceux qui ont voté pour Emmanuel Macron
premier tour sont très largement
favorables à la réforme les
sympathisants LR le sont aussi c'est
pour ça ce que vous disiez c'est quand
même compliqué parce que la base des
sympathisants LR globalement elle
soutient quand même en la réforme et à
l'inverse vous avez une très forte
opposition à gauche et au rassemblement
national Rémi Briand l'argument du
sauvetage de du régime des retraites on
l'a encore entendu dans la voie
d'Olivier du socle le ministre du
Travail tout à l'heure il a du mal à
infuser dans l'opinion comment vous
l'expliquer ça oui et puis comme
d'autres
là encore c'est pas le quoi qu'il en
coûte lié à la crise covid mais Emmanuel
Macron vient d'annoncer 400 milliards
pour réformer l'armée enfin bref est-ce
que 18 milliards dans l'opinion français
c'est plus rien je mets un peu les pieds
dans le plat volontairement provocateurs
évidemment c'est pas l'unité de
référence des Français et en plus
effectivement après ces deux années où
on a dit quoi qu'il en coûte on mobilise
les fonds publics etc forcément du point
de vue l'opinion là tout d'un coup dire
il faut de nouveau de la rigueur
budgétaire etc ça passe beaucoup moins
bien et c'est un discours celui de
l'équilibre budgétaire celui de la
nécessité de réformer qui a beaucoup
moins déco dans l'opinion par rapport à
ce qu'il pouvait être il y a encore deux
trois ans enfin trois quatre ans
maintenant avant le
covids Mathieu mais il faut quand même
en dire un mot quoi c'est ça donne la ça
donne un mot nul
mais ça donne la main et les filles
enfin d'une certaine façon il l'avait
déjà mais ça donne encore plus la main
et les filles pour mener cette ce combat
parce que on sait qu'au sein du PS il y
avait sur une ligne que personne ne
défendait
le PS soutenait à Hidalgo qui elle était
sur les 62 ans les Verts proposaient de
ne pas bouger et l'âge légal et là elle
est fille a réussi à imposer dans
l'accord de la nupes la retraite à 60
ans avec 40 nuts et les socialistes
perdrent en crédibilité perdent dans ce
débat là puisque ils sont pas d'accord
sur qui est premier secrétaire ils sont
profondément divisés profondément
fracturés et ils sont très mal à l'aise
il faut le dire sur ce dossier des
retraites puisque qui a apporté la durée
de cotisation à 43 ans Marisol Touraine
sous le quinquennat de François Hollande
dernier président socialiste merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat Benjamin Morel c'était ultra
clair le 47 ans
vous allez relever le défi merci
beaucoup à bientôt sur Public Sénat
évidemment on se retrouvera sur ce